regardez 1947 jean-françois gravier
écrire un livre qui est un titre
magnifique paris lé désert français 70
ans
on en est toujours au même point on en
est à faire des politiques aujourd'hui
de coeur de ville après avoir fait des
politiques de métropoles d'équilibré
politique de ville moyenne des
politiques toutes les politiques ont été
inventés et aujourd'hui bon on saupoudre
alors je trouve tout à fait légitime que
les villes moyennes cherche aujourd'hui
à se remettre dans le jeu
non seulement je trouve ça légitime mais
je soutiens et je travaille moi même
précisément sur ce sujet mais ça n'est
pas en disant aux gens venez habiter
dans la périphérie
vous allez doublé multiplier le nombre
de gilet jaune
c'est d'abord en se posant la question
de savoir comment on réindustraliser ce
pays
comment on produit du bien commun
comment on met en relation le centre de
ces villes moyennes avec les
périphériques qui sont complètement
déstructurée comment elles sont
désorientés aujourd'hui et donc c'est de
façon pragmatique qu'il faut ville par
ville commencé par dire voilà la vision
que l'on a de l'avenir
voilà le vrai projet que l'on a pour
vous et vous pouvez éventuellement
envisager de venir
mais si vous leur dites aujourd'hui on
est capable de faire des lotissements
vous allez venir vous en faites des gens
qui à l'évidence seront des malheureux
des oubliés de la société et des gens
qui seront perdus ou qui chercheront à
revenir en ville dans les vingt ou
trente années qui vont venir
[Musique]